♪ (MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
KATE WINSLET: When I
first read the script
written by Brad Ingelsby,
it completely
took my breath away.
Every episode ends
on a real cliffhanger.
I sat up till
the early hours of the morning,
reading every single episode.
I had never read a character
who was able to pull off so much
in terms of how she copes,
how she deals with people.
And she's extraordinary
at her job,
so I felt enormous admiration
for a person like that.
BRAD INGELSBY: Kate wanted
to pursue the character
in a way that was lovely
as a writer to have someone
who wants to put in the time
like that and dig deep.
Eventually, it became
Kate's creation.
I trusted her
to make dialogue changes,
because I felt convinced
that she knew this character
better than I did.
Kate was constantly
adding things, I mean,
we would rehearse
the scene, block the scene.
And then... she would say,
"Mare would
probably just do this."
Or like... "Should I
be eating something?
Like some junk food?"
Like how do we make
a new iteration of it
that's even more Mare?
It's definitely been,
I'd say, one of,
if not the most challenging
role I've ever played.
Just because
of how enormous it was,
the sheer volume of story,
the number of characters.
And then the dialect.
All right. Everybody,
put your gloves on.
Do a grid search. Mark anything
that seems out of place.
So we can photograph it.
KATE: Anyone from
Delaware County will know
that the dialect
is very complicated.
It's a very subtle one,
which makes it harder
to pick up.
And it can also sound Southern
if you don't do it right.
There were certain check-in
words that I would have,
like "water."
Get your water bottle ready.
The trickiest part
are the-- are the O's.
(DELAWARE ACCENT)
Going home alone,
on my own.
Which is very different to
"going home alone on my own."
I need to walk out of here
and go home.
And every once
in a while, I'd say,
"Brad, you've given
me seven O's in this one line!"
HELEN FAHEY: I don't know
what the hell to say.
Oh, wait. It just came to me.
That was stupid!
Goddamned idiotic!
SUSAN HEGARTY: If you're
working on a dialect,
you can start
with the sound changes.
You can start with
the rhythms, you can start
with certain melodies.
You can start anywhere.
You just chip away at it,
until you eventually can
pull the whole thing together.
Kate really does have
this prodigious work ethic.
We just drilled it and worked
it, and it was constant.
SUSAN: She was utterly
committed to doing this well,
to doing it properly,
to honoring the local culture.
And being able to shoot locally
like that is very helpful.
CRAIG ZOBEL: We were really
trying to be as specific
as we could to the area.
In addition to that, we would
like do it with costume.
Our costume designer
would be texting me pictures
from the Wawa convenience store.
Just of people in the line.
KATE: We would spend
so much time distressing
every item of clothing
with scrubbing brushes
and putting holes in things
and all her clothes
feel like clothes.
They don't feel like costumes.
I told the costume designer
that I wanted to wear
hip pads and butt pads.
And she practically cried
she was so happy.
She said, "Actresses
never ask me for that!"
Uh, we're just asking anyone
who knows anything
to please come forward.
Maybe it's a serial killer.
Christ, Mom.
Well, I mean,
it is the third girl, Mare.
♪ (SUSPENSEFUL MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
CRAIG:
A thing that became clear to me
while making the show
was that we were really talking
about people who'd been affected
by trauma, trying to learn
to move on from their trauma.
ANGOURIE RICE: There's a scene
where Siobhan comes home.
That's when all of the things
that she hasn't been able to say
or hasn't been allowed to say,
come out.
-You don't even talk about him.
-MARE SHEEHAN: What are you
talking about, Siobhan?
-Come on. Hey, come on--
-You don't even talk about him
anymore.
And I hate you for that,
I hate you!
You should have been the one
to find him.
-MARE: Stop!
-Not me, not me!
When I first read that scene
in the script, I just cried.
Sometimes as an actor,
it's just horrible
shooting certain scenes.
And that scene
was very upsetting
and, uh, extremely painful.
Kate and Angourie and I
had a conversation
about what is going
to make us feel
like we've achieved
a real moment.
Maybe have less people on set
and not necessarily have
the time pressure
that we would have
in a different scenario.
It was very, kind of,
intimate and personal.
It was just heartbreaking
to film.
It was very hard
to differentiate
between wanting to support
and help Angary
in performing the scene,
and having to also
keep so much reserved
because that's how Mare
handles the scene.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
(SOBBING)
Kate, as an actor,
she's so able to just
cover a gamut of emotions
and qualities
where you can see Mare
being super focused
on the work she's doing,
but at the same time is able to,
sort of, very closely
under the surface
is a very vulnerable woman
who needs to be loved
and wants to love, too.
Yeah, I think this was
kind of a one-time thing.
Well, does it have to be?
My life's complicated.
It was really clear for me
to see where Richard
would fit into her life,
and what was required to be
some sort of relief for Mare.
Do you ever
give yourself a break?
Are you about to tell me
I look exhausted?
No, but it seems like
you're carrying
a lot of heavy stuff,
and I, you know,
I wonder if anybody
ever does anything for you.
BRAD: We are dealing with dark
and tragic events in the show.
But I think
in order for an audience
to wanna stick around each week,
it can't be too heavy
all the time.
And so, the show has
a lot of humor in it.
CRAIG: There's a scene where
Evan says, "Goodnight, Mare."
And in one of the rehearsals,
the way he delivered it,
he was like...
Have a good nightmare!
Goodnight, Mare.
Why don't you have a good night,
Mare?
Craig and I thought
that was absolutely hilarious.
And I was like, "Wait,
just say that the next time."
And so,
we shot some of these things
that ended up in the show,
and messing around
and kind of finding it on set.
The first scene I shot was fun.
It's where we're at the funeral.
Listen up!
HELEN: And then
he announces out of guilt
in front of everyone
at his wife's wake.
I had an affair...
with Helen Fahey.
(MARE GRUNTS)
BRAD:
In spite of these tragic events,
there's a lot of laughter
in this community.
-(LAUGHING)
-Li-- Li-- Listen to me.
"Affair" is a strong word.
Very strong.
-It happened twice.
-(LAUGHING HYSTERICALLY)
Okay, three times, tops.
CRAIG:
The Wayne Potts sequence was
a particularly fun sequence
to design.
The location that we found was
a real location
that was a bar in the front
and a house in the back.
The set decoration was
incredible
and just looked
so real and scary.
KATE: Logistically, we had
to really understand the space.
We had to understand exactly
what would happen to Evan.
I think they did a countdown
like, "Three, two, one, bang!"
-(GUNSHOT)
-(GRUNTS)
They shot me doing that,
and then set up a pyrotechnic
that had blood in it,
and then shot that...
(IMITATES SPLATTERING)
...going on the wall.
And then the rest of the day,
I had a bullet hole in my face,
and I was laying on the ground.
(LAUGHS) Kate was running
all around my head,
and I'm like, "Please don't
step on me." (LAUGHS)
I had never held a gun
before playing this part.
-(GUNSHOTS)
-(MARE GASPS)
We didn't want her to come
off as an action star.
We wanted to make sure
that it read
as an unusual event
in the life of Mare Sheehan.
BRAD: The hardest part
of any mystery show really is
sticking the landing.
The ending has to be surprising,
and yet it has to be rewarding
as well.
JULIANNE NICHOLSON:
I was not able to predict
what was coming,
which is exciting. You wanna be
a part of something
where you don't know
what's coming next.
I always, like, theorize
about who'd done it,
and I never get it right.
So I was very shocked.
In a small town,
you have the opportunity
to sort of investigate
all the families
and to see the effects
that the crime has had
and get involved
in everybody's personal stories.
The suspect is wanted
in a murder investigation.
JULIANNE: The truth comes out,
and then the worst thing
in the world
that you can imagine,
as a mother, happens.
I think that moment in the car
where Lori blows up at Mare,
she's been holding
on to so much,
that it's just a moment
where it all comes out.
Why couldn't you just leave it
alone? It's my Ryan!
My Ryan!
Lori's life is completely ruined
because Mare figures it out.
CRAIG: We wanted
to make sure that landed
as a surprise and a twist,
but that you would have empathy
for characters
that you didn't before.
KATE: We worked so hard
to keep it a secret.
I hope that the audience
is as blown away as we all were
by who the real killer is.